[Music]
the sanderson sisters
are back what happened a virgin
lit the candle and no this time
a virgin didn't light the black flame
[Music]
candle
yep bette midler basically won halloween
giving fans of her hit 1993 halloween
flick hocus pocus
everything we've been waiting for a
reunion
is sister sister sister
i felt ready to wreak havoc the actress
rounded up her former co-stars
sarah jessica parker and kathy najimi
for her
annual halloween fundraiser benefiting
her non-profit
the new york restoration project which
works to restore gardens in parks in new
york's five boroughs
sisters we have been gone
300 years well how time flies
when you're dead and the one hour
virtual event
was freaking epic
[Music]
the whole thing was made to look like a
mock documentary about the history of
the sanderson sisters
and featured some familiar faces sharing
their own mock encounters with the
witches
yeah what the hell oh master
oh you've you've grown so much
older what the hell is a master yeah
like billy crystal john stamos glenn
close
jamie lee curtis george lopez tiffany
haddish
bella hadid todrick hall jennifer hudson
and merrell freaking streep okay
i'll tell this story but nobody believes
me
when i tell it oh but that's not all
thor birch who played danny in the flick
i thought that would never come
sisters greetings little one
it was i who brought you back imagine
and her on-screen big bro omri katz who
played max
also made cameos hey what's up sis
remember what you told me at grandma's
funeral
you promised not to talk about that well
are you still
yes i don't understand what's the big
deal lots of 44 year old guys haven't
done it
but the celeb appearances didn't end
there sarah silverman
martin short keenan thompson and adam
lambert
all got in on the fun too but it was the
finale that we
truly never saw coming the queen of
christmas made a cameo yes
i'm talking mariah harry
i got news for you girl halloween's
nearly over
so scat it's my turn now
get out bet
you just crushed that halloween can go
ahead and quit because it will never be
that good again
but this might not be the last time we
see our girls sarah mary and winnie
a hocus pocus sequel is in the works at
disney plus
set to be directed by adam shankman oh
my goodness me
oh i hope they get to me before i'm a
corpse and when etie caught up with
bette in september
she gave us the good news we were hoping
for
please tell me that you would be up for
coming back for it oh
absolutely yes yes absolutely
can't wait to fly oh my god i'm glad so
you're in
in yo yeah oh yeah we're just talking
well you know we're talking logistics
are you broad's a little old to be
trick-or-treating
we'll be younger in the morning
yeah sure me too and on halloween 2019
sjp responded to a fan on instagram who
asked about the sequel
writing we have all said yes now we wait
it's just a bunch of hocus pocus